sup
what is happening well with the new
captain coming in this is my chance to
reinvent myself
so say hello to chuck boyle office
badass wait a minute is that rose's
jacket and follow-up question does
rose's jacket fit you perfectly
you tell me you know you can't just put
on a leather jacket and become a badass
you also need a chunky bracelet with
fringe wrong ever since rosa gave me
this baby people have been treating me
like i'm cool the girl at the coffee
shop even got my name on the cup right
it says charles
not cassie you know i think it's less
about the jacket and more about the fact
that you're feeling confident maybe the
school version of charles was in there
all along
amy i love you but that's insane it's a
magic jacket so
just to be clear you think we're dealing
with a sisterhood of the traveling pants
situation here don't
know not familiar you made me watch it
look there's no point in rebranding
yourself for the new captain or should i
say crafton because they're not going to
be here for very long anyways remember
proud to stop it i don't want to hear
you bad-mouthing my replacement around
the office
do it surreptitiously watch this i hear
the new captain's a pill popper
what's up guys why are we standing
around outside
is your walk different are you strutting
what are you talking about it's how i
always walk [ __ ]
let's roll [ __ ] welcome the bar is in
the back and they're coming around with
food i use the most wonderful catering
company
they only hire x convicts to give them a
second chance oh that's wonderful
get in here and meet everyone oh
lieutenants i want to introduce you to
my old neighbor john he's the head of
admissions at the calder academy in the
bronx calder that's the best elementary
school in the city then my trial team
gets hired to work real cases
in a shuck my friend for major crimes is
here you're gonna love him maybe i will
maybe i won't well uh come on let's go
let me take your coat no i need
oh this way so cap tells me you're in
major crimes
yeah working something big
i can't tell you who the target is but
let's just say he's done a bunch of
disturbing things and he's on the
yankees
you play poker huh used to got tired of
winning all the time
well i have a weekly game it's mostly
broadway stars and celebrity chefs
not exactly my crowd but they are high
rollers
spot opened up you want in i don't know
seems kind of lame
but i'll stop by excuse me
i know you from somewhere did you go to
my gym ah
now i work out in my garage throw the
tire around grab a couple of big ropes
and do this
here's my number maybe i could come over
sometime and
i don't know you could work me out
this is the best night of my life people
believe i work out with ropes a mega
babe hit on me and that bartender didn't
assume i just wanted a bay breeze hey
you
cool guy were you flirting with my
girlfriend out back calm down hot shot
i'm taken
look i'll throw away her number that's
it you and me
outside oh brother come on guys i gotta
go squash this bug
look man i don't want any trouble
she's gonna leave me isn't she oh you're
crying of course you want someone like
you
you're so cool thank you it's true
what's your secret
how can i become more like you
here this is all you need it'll change
your life
trust me
did you just give away your magic jacket
oh terry it wasn't the jacket
i realized now that chuck was in here
i've had another man deep inside me this
whole time
welcome back charles all right away it
was the jacket
[Music]
terry terry terry
are you okay i'm fine but that dog came
right at me and i have no idea why
it looked like you had a lot of food in
your pockets what
no that's not true this jacket never had
any pockets this is the style
oh my god you did think i was poisoning
you i mean you were the one who said you
spent every day in prison dreaming of
the day we'd meet again
so i can prove to you unchained you said
you put something extra in my food
love you said it's so creepy look tone
is everything man
i've been talking to a cinderblock wall
for the last 10 years
i'm sorry if my social skills leave
something to be desired
that is a really good explanation
everybody the dog is leashed up out back
did anyone get hurt we're all fine
thanks to this guy
tackling a pit bull without spilling
your whiskey bad ass
it was nothing his teeth couldn't even
penetrate the jacket hey i have an
opening in a weekly poker game
you interested but you said i could come
i just think broadway star sudden
foster's gonna like the other guy a
little bit better
you